the next comedian is Hans can you guys
gonna be here I like to general says
chicken my Asian friends are like isn't
that just a shitty Americanized version
of something authentically Asian I'm
like yeah but so am i my favorite movies
rush hour 3 a big supporter of Andrew
yang because I think four people are
disgusting and we get rid of them by
giving up a lot of money I don't think
that's a culture I think that's what
people do when they're hungry we tag
them I was in the yang Yang I guess
we'll never get to live in a gangsta's
paradise really getting ready for the
yang bang I'm still a gangbanger for
life I think I've everyone got $1,000
every month you guys would be a lot more
bearable to be around here's some money
stop playing music on the bus
[Music]
I don't understand these CEOs for like
how am I supposed to motivate my
employees if I can't turn them with debt
I mean if I want people to work for my
company a company people want to work
for them with home cantilever wine
I love plays and I realize that if
you've written a play that's very
impressive
and if you've performed in a play that's
also very impressive
but if you've written and performed a
play that's not impressive at all
there's no checks and balances there
it's just a crazy person doing what are
the [ __ ] they want to do you mean like
jokes that ever written it performed I
was a small business just keeping it
real shoplifting doing my thing and the
small business owners like you're
hurting a small business you're hurting
a small business well technically I
haven't even smaller business I'm an
individual as small as the business
could be so out of my way big
corporation is something a little bit to
get a Snickers I don't like how Asian
women act like there's such hot [ __ ]
went back home we're throwing them away
we left the same patient validation
woman I get thrown away go be a salmon
[Laughter]
anyone can [ __ ] white dudes that's not
impressive
I love being Asian you know people make
fun of us because we dogs which I
understand to be horrific
because in America dogs are treated like
family members but in Asia we treat our
family members like family those does
very little tradition we have back home
where instead of buying an animal we
love our grandbaby girl always
considering the river
[Music]
oh my god I do you think people who play
Bluetooth speaker music out loud in
public have ever crossed paths with each
other I've never been like man that's it
going wait a minute I saw video where
this dude was like I use skateboarding
to express my emotions but I've never
needed a skateboard to do that I've
never been arguing with the girlfriend
have been like and bully had my
skateboard I can show you how to really
feel when you talk to your ex it makes
you feel like this I think I lost my job
recently and I think I'm gonna go play
in a locksmith because the locksmith is
never closed
they're always accepting applicants
that's not a clothes store that's a
puzzle and on the other side of the job
creeped out a business owner tomorrow
morning or you got 15 seconds well thank
you cops a cannon will anything can and
will be used against you in court alone
how about just camp now they have to use
it you know they're in the court of law
like excuse me he said I donate to local
charities and I have to use this now
against you so we all know how
inefficient that is haha take that
[Applause]